So suppose we have a
point mass particle
of mass m moving with
a velocity vector,
v. We can introduce
a quantity we call
the momentum of that particle.
I'll label it with the symbol p.
And it's equal to the product
of the mass times the velocity.
This is something you've
undoubtedly seen before.
Now, let's think
about the dimensions
of momentum for a moment.
So dimensionally,
momentum has units
of mass times the velocity.
And so that's in SI units, the
units of mass are kilograms
and then the units of velocity
are meters per second.
You can also express
momentum dimensionally
as a product of a
force times time.
And so, again in SI units,
units force are the Newton
and the units of
time is the second.
So these are the SI units for
momentum, two different ways
of writing the same dimensions.
Now, we've seen that
for a single particle,
we can write Newton's
second law as the force is
equal to the mass
times the acceleration.
Or equivalently,
we can write that
as the mass times
the time derivative
of the acceleration, dv/dt.
Now, if m is a constant,
then I can rewrite this as F
is equal to the time derivative
of the mass times the velocity,
or equivalently as the time
derivative of the momentum,
since mv is just equal to p.
So I actually want
to stress this much--
I'm going to put it
in a box because it's
very important that I can
write Newton's second law,
instead of F equals ma,
as F equals the time
derivative of the momentum.
And this is
absolutely where we'll
see the momentum
becomes very useful.
Because it turns out that this
form of Newton's second law
is actually the most
general form of the equation
because it's applicable not
just to a single point mass,
but also to a more
complicated system.
A system consisting
of many masses
or a system where
the masses changing
or the masses flowing,
as in a fluid.
In all of those cases, this
form of Newton's second law
is correct.
F equals ma, which is
probably more familiar to you,
is actually a special case
of this law for the case
of a single point mass.
So this is where we'll
see that momentum is quite
a useful concept, especially
as we start considering
more complicated systems, as
we'll get to a little later
in the course.
What I want to do now though,
is to take a closer look
at this equation, force is
equal to the time derivative
of the momentum.
Whenever we have a
relation involving
a derivative like this,
we can always also
rewrite it in an equivalent
integral form, which
can be very useful and give
us a different way of looking
at the same information.
So let's take a look at that.
So if I take this equation
and integrate both sides
with respect to time,
then I can write
that as the integral of
F with respect to time
is equal to the integral
of the right-hand side,
dp/dt with respect to time.
Now, let's make this
a definite integral.
I'll go from time t1 to
time t2 on both sides here.
Now, this right-hand
side is just--
so the integral of dp/dt
with respect to time
is just p at time2
minus p at time1.
And that is just the change
in the momentum vector
going from time1 to time2.
Now, this integral on
the left-hand side,
we give a special name.
We call this the impulse.
This name, impulse, calls to
mind a short, sharp, shock
of some sort.
But it can also
refer to a weak force
acting over a long interval.
And notice here the
function F, the force F,
is in general a
function of time.
So this doesn't necessarily
mean a constant f.
This could mean a force
that's varying in time.
And what this
equation tells us is
that the change in the
momentum of the system
doesn't depend on the
detailed time dependence of F,
but rather just on
the integral of F.
And so suppose I were to graph
the force as a function of time
going from time0
to a time delta t.
And suppose I had some
complicated function that
looked like that.
The impulse is just the
area under this curve.
It's the integral
of this function.
That's the impulse.
And the change in
the momentum depends
only on the area
under this curve
and not on the detailed
shape of the curve.
So what that means is that I
can define an average force
by choosing a
constant force that
has the same area as
this example on the left.
So suppose I calculated that.
And there is some
constant force here.
I'll call this F average.
Going over the
same time interval.
The average force is
that constant force
which has the same area as
the area under my F of t.
So in other words, F
average times delta t,
which is the area on the
right-hand side here,
is equal to the integral
of F of t dt integrated
from 0 to delta t,
which is the area
under this right-hand curve.
And so my average force is
just that integral, F of t dt,
divided by delta t.
And this is integrated
from 0 to delta t.
So that's my average force.